喜んでもらいたいという真心が本質じゃ
ないのかな。これ大事なとこなんだけど
思いはあるけど喜んでもらえてませんでは
ダメなんだよ。売りっぱなしはダメなん
ですよ。どんな価値ある商品でも満足と
いう状態にすることが真心だ。青木サの
人生哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる話
。
今回はですね、社員幸福度と顧客満足度のどちらを最優先すべきですかと。散方よし刑を実現するためにはどっちを優先させることが良いでしょうかということについて社長の考えをお聞かせください。
うん。なるほど。なるほど。面白い質問だね。
[音楽]
あのね、2人の子がいて、太郎君とはこ
ちゃん2人の子のどっちが大切ですか?
どっちを優先しなければなりませんか?
正解は両方だ。これが答えなんだよ。私は
ね、社員幸福度も顧客満足度も社会貢献度
も真剣に3つ追求してきました。ただこれ
ね、明確に言えることは社員の幸福って何
って言われた時に当然働く環境の問題や
それから職場の人間関係やそれから仕事で
の働きだとかやりがいというような重要感
証人とかそういう仕事を通して得られる
もの精神的なものですよね。それから具体
的な経済的な報酬、自分がやはり働いて
られる価値というものに対しての納得感。
そして楽しい仕事が楽しい。つまり主体的
に自らの意思で仕事ができる。つまり
やらされ感ではないってことよね。この5
つのことを本気で与えたいと思って頑張っ
てきました。最初はないんだよ、これ。
正直もうマンションオフィスでスタートし
て本当に過酷な労働条件の中で生き残ら
なきゃいけないだ。そう思って一生懸命
頑張ってきた。ただその思いはあった。
思いはあるけど実際は結果はついてきて
ない。同じように家族を幸せにしたい。
配偶者を幸せにしたいと思った。だけど
実際は苦労をかけた。でも思いはあった。
これ同じだよね。だからその思いがまず
大事なんだよ。その思いを具限化するには
どうしたらいいかって言うと、お客様味方
にするしかないんだよ。てことはお客様を
味方にするっていうことはどういうこと
かって言うとお客様が満足しない限り味方
にならないもん。裏切られたってことに
なるわけだ。逆に味方の反対は敵だから
倒産するような会社ってお客様を敵にし
てるんですよ。不誠実な人は絶対長続きし
ないよね。物の見方考え方の中にやっぱり
誠実さ、誠実さを補うスキルは存在しない
と。お金もらう以上はそのお金の何倍もの
リターンやっぱお客様に対して喜んで
もらいたい。この喜んでもらいたいという
真心が本質じゃないのかな。いい、これ
大事なとこなんだけど、それは思いはある
けど喜んでもらえてません。ではダメなん
だよ。まったなしなのよ、これは。だから
自分で商品開発できなかったら仕入れる
しかないよ。価値ある商品を扱ってる会社
の社長に頭下げて扱わしてくださいって
言って顧客満足は商品力なんですよ。だ
から製品プラスアフターサービスで商品力
になると売りっぱなしじゃダメなんですよ
。どんな価値ある商品でも。で、これ使え
ないのはあなたのせいですよねっていうの
もダメなんですよ。それを説明をして購入
いただいた以上は満足という状態にする
ことが真心なんだよ。だ、それを社員
みんなでそこに向かう。それは社員のね、
人数も少ない時、労働環境も良くなかった
けれども、お客様に対しての真心は
100%の気持ちで社員みんなで向かっ
てったよね。でもその結果得られた利益、
お客様から頂いた利益を納税し
、そして社員に分配をし、未来のために
内部流保して役員でも分配しながらあとは
社会に還元するということを長年にわって
追求してきたわけだ。だから散方しって
考えだよね
。顧客満足、社員幸福度、社会貢献度、
この3つのはの3つを追求していく。だ
から社会貢献はやっぱりその事業の内容
社会的な仕事は絶対しない。ま、僕は出版
社も代表しで会長してるけれども、どんな
に儲かるって言われても自殺マニュアル
みたいなものは出さない。ま、僕はだから
採用のコンサルティングのあの仕事も、あ
、この会社信用できないなと思ったら断っ
ちゃう。だからお金じゃないわけよ。
やっぱり社員幸福度とね、顧客満足度で
顧客満足だけ優先してるんならそれ取る
じゃん。どんな仕事でも。でもやっぱり
社員幸福度考えたらいや取らない。
この仕事はやっぱり社会と共に社員と共にお客様と共に共に歩むアチューメントなんだよね。そんな感じかな。
ありがとうございます。
同時にやっぱりこう大事にし続けるっていうこの判断基準を磨くためには何からしたらいいんですかね。
[音楽]
だから目的に生きるってこじゃないの?目標に生きるんじゃなくて目先の利益に生きるんじゃないんだよ。
だ、儲かれば何でもいいじゃないかとかだ
なんかね、ま、いろんな会社があるから
それは主義主張があっていいんだ
けど儲かれば何でもいいじゃないかとは僕
は思わないんだよね。やっぱりこの仕事で
こういう価値を作り出していきたい。こう
いうところになんだろう。我々の仕事の
ミッションがある。そこはやっぱり
こだわりたいね。僕は研修でも外的
コントロール的な無社員にきつく言えない
ので私たちの代わりに社員を叱って
くださいみたいな研修とか音社ね代わりに
もうあの馴じり倒してくださいみたいなね
。一切そんな仕事受けないよね。あ、
ちょっとごめんなさいと。私たちは恩社の
宝である社員をより価値のある人間にする
ためにお仕事のお手伝いはしますけれども
社長の不満解消のために研修使うような
ことは考えない方がいいですよと。これは
もううちに仕事出すと私たちが大臣してる
価値観が浸透して帰って社長が求めてる
もの手に入んなくなりますからうちはやめ
た方がいいですってことあるぐらいだ。だ
から周りの会社がアチュメントすごいです
ね。公衆収益体質でって言うけどでもそれ
はお客様を見方にしてお客様の口コみに
よって営業マーケティングのコストが
すごく低く抑えられてで価値ある商品に
それが転換したり採用の方に投資ができて
だ2027年の採用には今7000万の
採用予算取ってるわけじゃん。それ全部
そういう風にこう未来のためにお金が富の
循環が起こってくんだよね。だから顧客
満足を永続的にってことはやっぱり価値
ある商品を磨き続けなきゃいけない。お客
様フォローの仕組みをどうしたら実現
できるかとか理想が高ければ高いほどお金
かかるのよ。もそれやっぱり稼がなきゃ
いけない。だけど稼ぐっとなった時社員を
犠牲にはしない。同じように休み増やそう
としてるよね。リモート増やすとかどうな
んだろうな。このバランスやっぱり
バランス感覚じゃないかな。宇宙は
バランスで成り立ってんですよ。バランス
を書いたら結果的におかしくなります。だ
から大きくするんじゃなくて質を追求し
続けていくこと。その結果大きくなる分に
は繁栄がずっと続く。ま、そういう風に僕
は考えてます。
両方大事にしてくださいと。こけがいと
いうか、要は子供の盾を言ったけどね、
2人の兄弟がいたらね、2人とも大事、3
人いたら3人とも大事だと平等にきっちり
と。ただし3人のうち誰かが病気になって
たら当然その病気の子をちゃんとケアをし
なきゃいけないだろうしの状況によっては
変わるかもしれない。でも心は平等に
やっぱりそこを追求していく。そういう
ことなんだと思います。私はフェアである
ことをすごく大事だと思ってんですね。
原理原則に従って対顧客対社員対社会に
対して誠実な経営を貫それが繁栄の本質だ
とそういう風に考えます。是非ね
チャンネル登録またしてみてください。
そして何かインスパイア、気づきがあっ
たらコメント欄に是非お願いします。私も
たくさんの本も書いてますし、また拒否を
築づく思考法ナポレオンヒルの本を今回、
え、新役で役者として出しましたので是非
これも読んでください。私は23歳の時に
このスク&グローリッチに出会って人生が
変わりましたので是非お勧めしたいと思い
ます。え、今一押しですね。よろしくお
願いします。また次の番組で会いましょう
。どうもありがとうございます
[音楽]
。あ、もっとすごい話をしよう。実は昔私
はね、6日働いて1日休むっていうことを
ずっと守ってきた会社なのよ。それで
随分昔の話なんだけど、ある社員が日曜日
僕の目を盗んで仕事をしてた。で、それを
えって聞いたの。え、なんで日曜日は働か
ないって方針じゃないか。いや、だけど
日曜日に研修してもらいたいってお客さん
がいるんですよ。あ、そうかと。じゃあ
他者に行ってもらうしかないよね。それは
と社長売上ですよ。だ、いや、待ってと。
まず、ま、バイブルにも6日働いて1日休
めってあるから1日は家族の日にしなさい
と
。で、家族が幸せだったら仕事に
対するも出るし、健康的にも1日は絶対
集める。昔だから集ね、2日じゃないんだ
よ。月4日の休みみたいな。6日働いて1
日休み。週急1日みたいな会社だったの。
アチメント。いや、本当にそういう歴史が
あるで。ある時、それでも日曜日働くから
日曜日の経費を出さないことしたの俺。そ
したら大問題が起きたのよ。その人間はま
、結果やめるってことになったわけで彼が
言ったのはお客様に食べさせてもらってる
じゃないですかと。我々はお客様に食べ
させてもらってるんだから。お客様が
日曜日って言ってるんだから日曜日仕事
するのが本水じゃないですか?お客様大地
ですよねって。いや、ちょっと待てと。僕
はそういう経験者じゃないと。まだ会社
まだちっちゃかったんだよ
。1日は家族と過ごして欲しいんだと。6
日働休みと。もしくは交代機をちゃんと
取ってプランニングをした上でともかく過
に働いて研修の仕事ってどうしても休みの
日にやろうとしてしまう
から家族が犠牲になっちゃうんだよと。そ
したら幸せにならないぞ。だからちゃんと
計画を立てて1日でいいから1週間1日で
当時はね今は月9日休みよ。でも昔は創業
当時は月に1日でいいから休みなさいと
健康も大事だしって。ほら、だからこれ
すごい社員のことを思って言ってたのよ。
でも結果彼はあのやめちゃったんだよね。
すごく残念でした。でもずっと僕は日曜日
は働かないっていうのを通してきた。それ
で佐藤江郎さんも守られてトレーナーで彼
は個人事業者でずっとうちに入る前休んだ
ことないんだから。それはそうだよ。
日曜日も研修があるの。1日も休まずさよ
。それでも家族を射戦するために頑張って
た。でもうちに入って休みがちゃんと
取れる。年間計画を立てて休める。これ
大事なんですよ。松下さんは集2日を実現
したじゃん。俺集3日にチャレンジしたい
と思った。40期マジに。でもそれが可能
かどうかはもちろんね、研修系の仕事だと
どうしてもコーディネーターっていうか、
あの色々ね、仕事が雑用もあるから社員数
増やさなきゃいけなかったり、もしくは
登録性にして外部からの協力もらうとか
いろんなこと考えなきゃいけないのかも
しれないんだけど、僕はともかく社員幸福
度と顧客満足度と社会貢献度、この3つを
同時にバランスを取って実現し続けていく
そういう経営をこれからも追求していき
たいと思います
[音楽]
。決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身
がお金よりも仕事の内容をそのものに
掘れ込んでるかどうかなです。